[Musik]
er wird dieser musik nicht hören
er wird seine inszenierung nicht sehen
[Musik]
denn grill serie branekov regisseur von
cosi fan tutte am zürcher opernhaus
steht seit anderthalb jahren in moskau
unter hausarrest
die premiere jedoch fand statt
[Musik]
wir kommen auf dem burgplatz heute ist
premiere hier im opernhaus zürich
mozarts cosi fan tutte das klingt nach
zauberhafter musik noch einer
vergnüglichen verwechslungskomödie doch
dieser abend ist eine premiere mit
politischer brisanz dass diese primär
überhaupt stattfinden
mozart in einer modernen wohnküche
diese szene hat regisseur kiril
serebrennikow in moskau entworfen im
hausarrest weit weg von zürich wo sie
nur gespielt wird und sie ist typisch
serebrennikow sein theater ist wild voll
starker bilder und extremer gefühle
[Musik]
serebrennikow produziert in hohem tempo
voller unrast voller fantasie theater in
moskau
dazwischen filme sein letzter hertha
über die untergrund rockszene der 1980
er jahre lief im wettbewerb von cannes
[Musik]
der fotos seiner fantasie die themen die
ihn und treiben das sind gewalt
sexualität religion die seelischen
konflikte der gegenwart die er mit
geschichten aus der vergangenheit
konfrontiert wie in seiner mozart
inszenierung hier in zürich
[Musik]
cosi fan tutte und der fall
serebrennikow wir waren in moskau die
hintergründe aufzudecken und fragen wie
frei ist die kunst in russland und wir
haben die außergewöhnlichen proben hier
in zürich begleitet doch zuerst montag
am theater in der oper ist alles möglich
alles kann gespielt werden
alles kann entstehen probenarbeit anfang
oktober
eigentlich sieht es aus wie eine ganz
normale probe ein dirigent eine
dramaturgin
[Musik]
der stab der mitarbeiter nur der
regisseur fehlt stattdessen leitet sein
engster mitarbeiter ihre gene colan
[Musik]
immer wenn ich mit ihm zusammenarbeite
suchen wir die gemeinsamkeit der
konzepte alle geschichten sind von
carril ausgedacht und dem klavierauszug
notiert was ich jetzt mit den sängern
mache entspricht hundertprozentig seinen
vorstellte seinen wünschen seinen ideen
hier sich für die handlung überlegt hat
[Musik]
entwickelt kirill serebrennikow ideen
weiter
die in klavierauszug notiert sind detail
für detail bewegung für bewegung
der regisseur ist anwesend und abwesend
zugleich
es hat niemand damit rechnen können dass
was passieren würde
es war absolut nicht zu erwarten er war
einfach ein super erfolgreiche toller
interessanter regisseur der nicht nur
filme macht sondern auch sprechtheater
und in der oper mehrere erfolge schon
hatte und wir fanden ihn einfach
unheimlich toll und wollten ihn gerne
bei uns in der oper haben dass das
passieren würde damit hat kein mensch
gerechnet
[Musik]
wir alle sind sehr bewegt wie marcel
brenne kräftig über einem jahr nun
täglich 22 stunden in einer kleinen
wohnung zu bringen muss ohne kontakt zur
außenwelt und auch körperlichen kontakt
das ist wirklich eine ganz schlimme
situation
moskau mitte oktober während in zürich
geprobt wird verlängert hier das gericht
den hausarrest für grill serebrennikow
bei seiner ankunft gibt es kein halten
mehr
denn gefilmt werden darf nur vor dem
gebäude der prozessauftakt findet unter
ausschluss der öffentlichkeit statt
bilder vom tag seiner verhaftung im
august 2017 kiril serebrennikow der
regie berserker der ohne arbeit nicht
leben kann
gefangen in einem käfig mehr als ein
jahr dauerten die voruntersuchungen die
nun zur anklage führen
ihm wird vorgeworfen über 133 millionen
rubel umgerechnet 2 millionen franken
veruntreut zu haben
er habe das vertrauen der mitarbeiter
des kulturministeriums missbraucht
dieser ordner beinhalten beweisstücke
für den prozess die buchhaltung der
theatergruppe siebtes studium
serebrennikow soll gelder für projekte
veruntreut haben die nie realisiert
wurden subventionen seien stattdessen in
die taschen der theatermacher geflossen
wir haben den behörden mitgeteilt dass
wir jede einzelne veranstaltung über
oft haben jede vorstellung jeder staat
um die tickets der jeweiligen
veranstaltungen die zahlen wie viele
zuschauer die vorstellungen gesucht
haben die werbung die geschaltet wurde
es gibt die listen der mitarbeiter die
damals beschäftigt waren vom regisseur
bis zum bühnentechniker wir haben die
behörden aufgefordert fragen sie doch
die leute dann viel geld sie erhalten
haben wenn man das alles zusammenzählt
kommt man auch den betrag der für die
vorstellungen insgesamt ausgegeben wurde
doch das interessiert die behörden nicht
von den aufführungen die angeblich nie
stattfanden gibt es videos die stücke
werden zum teil bis heute gespielt
wenn aber die vorwürfe der anklage
haltlos sind was steckt in wahrheit
dahinter soll ein unbequemer
theatermacher zensuriert oder mundtot
gemacht werden
die kritikerin marina dawydowa hier bei
einer diskussion über zensur in russland
grenzt die praktiken der kulturbehörde
wenn sie mit einem beamten sprechen wird
dieser sagen bei uns alles zensur gegen
wir verbieten niemandem etwas
jeder kann machen was er will es gibt
aber einen finanzielle zensur wenn einer
aus der reihe tanzt dann kommt die
finanzkontrolle und wenn die
finanzkontrolle etwas finden will wird
sie etwas finden denn die vorschriften
sind bei uns so absurd dass es nicht
möglich ist alle vorschriften
einzuhalten alle verstoßen gegen gewisse
vorschriften alle wenn die
finanzkontrolle morgen das tschechow
künstler theater kontrolliert das
bolschoi theater das mariinsky theater
dass alexander ins theater in welchem
berühmten theater auch immer die
finanzkontrolle wird etwas finden die
frage bei wem kommt die finanzkontrolle
vorbei zurück vor gericht erstmals zu
gesicht bekommen wir kiril serebrennikow
in der mittagspause
bewacht von mitarbeitern der
justizbehörden
aber sprechen dürfen wir ihn nicht denn
seit er unter hausarrest steht ist der
kontakt zu medien untersagt um den
prozess gegen ihn nicht zu beeinflussen
am ende des ersten tages tritt sein
anwalt an die öffentlichkeit
scheinbar unbemerkt von russischen
fernsehkameras verlässt kiril
serebrennikow den gerichtssaal
auch auf dem nachhauseweg ist er in
ständiger begleitung unsichtbar
die fußfessel die all seine bewegungen
festhält nur zwei stunden am tag dafür
hier in der umgebung seiner wohnung
spazierengehen zwei stunden von 18 bis
20 uhr treffen darf er sich auch dann
mit niemandem der einzige der ihm zu
hause besuchen darf ist sein anwalt
darin nennt mich scherzhaft seinen
regieassistenten weil die ganze
kommunikation mit zürich und seinem co
regisseur jeff kinney kollegen für mich
läuft jewgeni kollegin setzt vor ort die
anmerkung von kirill um die er zuvor von
mir erhalten hat er schickt mir dann
wiederum aufnahmen der proben die ich an
kirche weitergebe so läuft die
zusammenarbeit bei cosi fan tutte ein
neuer probentag in zürich vier wochen
vor der premiere über serebrennikow sun
wald ist eine videobotschaft in zürich
eingetroffen
so umgeht man die strengen auflagen der
moskauer justiz
zuerst hören wir ein paar vorschläge von
kirin zu den letzten szenen
er ist sehr begeistert und inspiriert
von der letzten phase mit den erotischen
episoden ich werde heute nur kurz
kommentieren und die proben nicht durch
lange kommentare aufzuhalten
heute ist kurz regiearbeit aus 2500
kilometern entfernung in seiner kleinen
30 quadratmeter wohnung erläutert kiril
serebrennikow seine konzeption kämpft
gegen seine isolation
das ist glaube ich das was ihnen im
moment seelisch am leben erhält dass er
zumindest das gefühl hat es hier wird
weiter gearbeitet an seinem konzept und
er kann da den gedanken auch teilhaben
ich glaube das ist extrem wichtig es für
ihn natürlich ohne zweifel ist das
wichtig für jemanden dessen energie für
zwei inszenierungen reicht und ein
dritter noch im kopf der drehbücher
schreibt das kino trinkt gleichzeitig
meetings und proben organisiert und der
darf dann nur noch in einem kleinen
zimmerchen seien 30 quadratmeter groß
das ist schwer und unerträglich und das
einzige was dich da retten kann ist die
arbeit
mediziner und das passiert keine chance
rebellin die kof beschreibt sehr genau
was er wie vor in der tagen will der
stelle wo sie die strümpfe aus zieht
setz dich frontal auf das bett damit das
aus team frontal vom zuschauer gesehen
wird und mach es nicht stehen stehen das
nicht schön und nicht bequem sitzend ist
es besser für uns ist eine unterstützung
seiner energie sehr wichtig zu sehen wie
reagiert wir alles beschreibt wie er es
sogar selber spielt das können wir als
grundlage
er kommentiert sehr ausführlich jede
szene und korrigiert sie und das nehmen
wir die darstellung zu verfeinern
ja and stop noch 14 tage bis zur
premiere von nun an soll auf der
opernbühne geprobt werden
das bühnenbild wird aufgebaut
ein aufwendiger raum den kiessee
branekov gemeinsam mit seinem
bühnenbildner nicolai simon of entworfen
hat wir versuchen das beste aus der
situation zu machen
aber es ist schwierig normalerweise ist
der regisseur da hier aber fehlt
serebrennikow idee für den raum ist ein
grauer moderner bunker zweistöckig ein
oben und ein unten eine simultan bühne
auf der er die geschlechterbeziehungen
zwischen mann und frau im hier und jetzt
betrachten kann
in der inszenierung haben die männer
doppelgänger und deshalb entstehen auch
diese zwei ebene so befinden sich zum
beispiel die seelen der männer auf der
zweiten ebene ihre doppelgänger aber auf
der erste
so entstehen parallel räume deswegen
haben wir zwei stockwerke geworden
cosi fan tutte mozarts
verwechslungskomödie beschreibt ein
experiment
zwei männer testen ihre verlobten auf
ihre treue
sie geben vor in den krieg zu ziehen
kommen verkleidet zurück und verführen
die verlobte des sie als andere so
lustig so unglaubwürdig serebrennikow
hingegen lässt anstelle der sänger zwei
schauspieler zurückkehren um die frauen
zu verführen
die schauspieler sind die hüllen die
körper die sänger geben ihnen die
sprache füllen sie mit seele
[Musik]
es ist ein niederträchtiges spiel bei
dem die männer die regeln vorgeben und
die frauen hilflos erlegen sind
[Musik]
beleuchtungs probe der video regisseur
elia chagall auf komplettiert nun das
regie team das er der blick aufs bild
ideen umsetzen wird
als regisseur kein diktator
er ist eher ein inspirator als regisseur
er inspiriert dich und du kannst du als
künstler seine eigenen ideen in die
arbeit ein
[Musik]
wir nehmen diese technische probe auf
und zeigen is killing und dann können
wir korrigieren
er fehlt immer natürlich im moment macht
er sich gerade gedanken an das
lichtkonzept müssen auch da hat er klare
vorstellungen
das räderwerk der theater maschinerie
funktioniert reibungslos
trotz abwesenden regisseur was ist nur
an kiril serebrennikow ideen so anstößig
dass er zur zielscheibe juristische
angriffe wurde das kontrollzentrum in
moskau
nach wie vor steht das theater hinter
seinem künstlerischen leiter der die
einstmals verstaubte sowjetische bühne
in einen ort für zeitgenössisches
theater verwandelte hier wird mit
konservativen traditionen gebrochen und
konsequent auf innovation auf neue
formen gesetzt auf ein junges ensemble
mit ungewöhnlichen ideen philipp aber
die fw ist schauspieler in diesem
ensemble entweder kämpft sie sich
alleine durchs leben oder du hast so
viel geld wie wir die mit kirill
jemanden kennengelernt haben wir uns
durch diesen chaotischen ozean des
lebens führt und mit seinen erfahrung
weiterhilft
in erster linie ist er für mich eine
wichtige autorität an welche ich immer
mit fragen der land heben kann
er ist für mich ein großer lehrmeister
philipp aber es zeigt uns das theater
die ränge im google zentrum sind
regelmäßig ausverkauft serebrennikow
inszenierungen sind erfolgreich locken
das russische publikum mit radikalem
gegenwartstheater gewalt nacktheit
homosexualität nationalismus
serebrennikow bricht mit tabus dieses
stück trägt den titel die schweine hunde
ein affront für die mehrheitlich
konservative theaterszene in russland
[Musik]
in der gegenwärtigen zeit im jahr 2018
ist er nicht mehr einfach irgendein
regisseur sondern ein symbol für das
neue theater in russland eine person mit
einem sehr starken image in der arbeit
von kiril widerspiegeln sich wie durch
ein prisma viele unserer heutigen
probleme politische wirtschaftliche und
gesellschaftliche probleme unserer
realität
offiziell steht er nicht wegen seiner
themen vor gericht doch die
anklagepunkte seien vorgeschoben
davon ist marina dawydowa überzeugt
zeitgenössische kunst provoziert beim
publikum eine kritische
auseinandersetzung mit der realität in
diesem sinne werden alle versuche leute
kritisches denken näher zu bringen als
mögliche gefahr wahrgenommen
man kann es so sehen ich denke nicht
dass auch nur irgendein beamter in einem
kulturministerium das für sich so
formulieren würde
die beamten machen es nicht bewusst
sondern sie machen dies von sich aus
automatisch das verwaiste arbeitszimmer
von serebrennikow auch hier suchten
mitarbeiter der untersuchungsbehörden in
sturmmasken nach beweismaterial ein
versuch die gesamte kulturszene
einzuschüchtern
ich werde oft gefragt ob es einen
zweiten fall geben wird wie bei
celebrity kopf und einem dritten wer
könnte der nächste sein
ich sage dann dass kein weiterer fall
nötig ist ein fall reicht bereits mehr
als aus alle haben klar verstanden dass
es grenzen gibt die man nicht
überschreiten soll
[Musik]
hinter diesen türen an der oper in
zürich entsteht nun also kiril
serebrennikow vision der mozart oper
cosi fan tutte heute zehn tage vor der
premiere steht die klavier hauptprobe
auf dem programm das bedeutet das
ensemble muss sich nun auf der großen
bühne orientieren oder an die einzelnen
stränge der inszenierung wie kostüme
licht und bühnenbild finden jetzt
zusammen
und es wird sehr deutlich wie chris
helmig auf die handlung der oper mit der
gegenwart konfrontiert
[Musik]
seine figuren sind menschen von heute
mozarts experiment und die treue der
frauen konfrontiert er mit bildern die
den kampf um die rechte der frau um
selbstbestimmung zeigen
[Musik]
da blitzt plötzlich der geist von
pussycat dolls opernhaus und stellt die
moral ja die geschichte die cosi fan
tutte erzählt völlig infrage
[Musik]
[Applaus]
noch gibt es viel zu tun viel zu
besprechen
auch mit opernhaus intendant andreas
homoki außergewöhnliche probe kann man
wirklich sagen wie läuft das
normalerweise die probe der vielen
pannen und der vielen entdeckungen was
alles noch schief läuft und noch nicht
gut ist und noch korrigiert werden muss
dafür läuft es sehr gut
die eigentliche regiearbeit vor ort hat
sein langjähriger assistent übernommen
war das ein risiko fürs opernhaus zürich
ja natürlich ist das immer ein risiko
wenn man ungewöhnliche wege geht und
eine situation wo man wo man sagt der
regisseur der eigentlich nicht nur das
ganze planen muss vor konzipieren muss
sondern dann letztlich sechs wochen vor
ort sein muss um mit den sängern die
dinge einzustudieren wenn der fehler
klar ist das ein risiko
und die frage war kann ihn jemand
ersetzen vor ort und von kirill kam
selber der vorschlag ihrer kollegin
dafür einzuladen sein langjähriger
assistent und choreograf und es läuft
eigentlich noch besser als erwartet und
als gehofft sie haben sich entschieden
diese inszenierung auch ohne regisseur
durchzuführen ist das ein politisches
zeichen das opernhaus zürich heisst für
mich vor allem menschliches zeichen dass
werden diesem künstler der der massiv
angegriffen wird der massiv beschädigt
werden soll der kaputt gemacht werden
soll dadurch ein regisseur der nicht aus
dem haus raus kann das noch mal was
anderes als ein schriftsteller oder ein
maler der dann noch arbeiten kann man
braucht das theater er braucht die
öffentlichkeit aber auch den schritt den
kontakt zu einem ensemble und das
abzuschneiden
das finden wir in fahren da wir auch
diese diese
anschuldigungen für fadenscheinig halten
so lange da nichts entschieden es gilt
für uns die unschuldsvermutung und der
wunsch diesen künstler zu helfen und und
hier nicht dazu beizutragen den kapuzen
der russische staat macht serebrennikow
einen dubiosen prozess setzen ein
zeichen der solidarität könnte müsste
man noch mehr machen aus zürich aus der
schweiz hinaus zum beispiel ich weiß
nicht in welche politischen appelle aus
dem westen nach russland haben noch nie
viel gefruchtet
ich denke dass das was wir tun ist
eigentlich das wirkungsvollste wenn wir
verhindern dass dieser künstler mundtot
gemacht wird es sind nur noch wenige
tage bis zur aufführung und das
opernhaus bled zur sonntags matinee um
über die außergewöhnliche inszenierung
zu informieren und auch zur replik auf
selbst richtet sich an das zürcher
publikum
wir finden das video zu leben die kof
ein toller künstler ist und dass seine
vision dieses stückes hier in zürich auf
die bühne gebracht werden sollte es ist
also wenn sie so wollen ein statement
für die freiheit der kunst
am 2 november 2018 findet zwei tage vor
der premiere die generalprobe statt
ja natürlich bin ich nervös es ist eine
wirklich große aufführung eeg nicola
ging hat hier in zürich bewiesen dass am
theater alles möglich ist dass im
theater alles entstehen kann
selbst wenn der regisseur im hausarrest
sitzt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich bin manchmal gefragt worden ob die
situation in der krise bremst befindet
in dieser inszenierung auch sichtbar
wird ob sie vielleicht sogar thema sei
am anfang habe ich gedacht nein sie ist
nicht thema mittlerweile spüre ich aber
mehr und mehr dass die haltung wir
lassen uns nicht beugen dass diese
haltung sehr wohl eigentlich fast jeder
sekunde in dieser inszenierung deutlich
wird
[Musik]
man darf keine angst
man darf keine angst haben die angst
frisst die seele auf
die angst macht unser bernig man muss
einfach die eigene wahrheit kennen und
diese wahrheit immer beschützen
wir arbeiten weiter das ist unsere
barrikade unsere wahrheit
[Musik]
ja auch dieser opernabend mehr sagen wir
dass ein zeichen der solidarität das
wissen wir noch nicht klebrig oft bleibt
unter anklage bleibt isoliert unter
hausarrest insofern ist der heutige
opernabend ganz bestimmt der
politischste der saison
wer mehr sehen will von kiril
serebrennikow ab mitte november in
unseren kinos die chance hat dann läuft
sein film unter dem titel leto der von
der liebe zur freiheit erzählt gleich
jetzt schaut dawkins russland nach der
oktoberrevolution vor 100 jahren und wir
besuchen aber auch ein atelier nahe
fribourg wo künstlerinnen und künstler
arbeiten die wir vermeintlich normalen
menschen geistig behinderten kommen sie
gut durch die woche
[Applaus]
[Musik]